if you're not pursuing your interests in
life you're not realizing who you really
are an entrepreneur could be a business
person could be an artist could be a
musician
anybody who can have an idea and turn it
into reality your business can always go
away you can never get complacent
because I've I've had it all taken away
from me before I actually was pretty
depressed when I graduated from college
I was literally depressed for like six
months as soon as you are losing steam
you've got to bring people into your
business that can add a relentless
passion to it and the light bulb went
off and it was literally like I could
see GoPros mounted all over the place
and I got chills are you laughing my
wife is laughing I made the Dean's List
he's an American businessman and
philanthropist he's the founder and CEO
of GoPro he has an estimated net worth
of seven hundred and seventy million
dollars
he's Nick Woodman and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success number ten
is my personal favorite I make sure to
stick around all the way to the end for
some special bonuses we all have
interests and passions for a reason it's
your inner voice telling you what you
should be doing with your life if you're
not pursuing your interests in life
you're not realizing who you really are
and as a result you're not gonna be as
happy as you can be what is the word
entrepreneur mean to you when somebody
can take an idea and make it real
and so that an entrepreneur could be a
business person could be an artist could
be a musician anybody who can have an
idea and turn it into reality and how
did you do that I dedicated myself to it
when I was 22 years old I promised
myself that I would work my tail off
until the age of 30 at a minimum to
succeed as an entrepreneur and that was
extremely important because I had a lot
of failure along the way right the first
company he started Phil yeah actually
and then there was a company that I
didn't even start that I failed at so I
really had two failures before I
succeeded with GoPro how do those
failures drive you today well at the
time they scared me
and failure isn't easy it wasn't like I
thought oh cool I failed and success has
taught me that one of the most important
things an entrepreneur can have is
perseverance a dedication a willingness
to fail pick yourself up again and give
it another shot because if you don't
have that if you don't have that grit
you're gonna get run over started in
2002 let's talk about that initiation of
the dream how did that start and how'd
that come about I'd started a business
before that I raised 4 million bucks of
other people's money started a web
marketing company went boom and bust
with the first dot-com boom and bust I
knew I wanted to make it as an
entrepreneur and start another business
but I had no idea what I wanted to do
and so for inspiration I went surfing
and I planned a five-month surf trip
around Australia and Indonesia the
inspiration came before I even left I
wanted to capture photos of myself and
my friends that I was going on the trip
with while we were surfing out in the
water and no camera existed that allowed
you to do that and so I set out to
develop this wrist harness that I could
put a single-use disposable camera into
and surf with it and I didn't even mean
it to be a business idea I just wanted
to document my experience on this trip
and as soon as I got it working well the
light bulb went off and I realized oh my
god there must be so many other surfers
in the world that wants something like
this so you started with wrist straps
essentially but how do you go from wrist
straps which are very simple to hardware
into actually developing a camera I
wanted to use higher quality cameras
with my wrist strap to capture higher
quality photos but every camera that I
would use with the strap surfing I would
break the camera because cameras weren't
designed to be used during rigorous
activities like surfing and what I ended
up doing was I spent two years going to
trade shows the camera trade shows
around the world to look for a camera
that was close to what I would want to
design after a year and a half about a
year I found it and got the manufacturer
to agree to make the modifications and
begin building the cameras for me I
actually did the deal without ever
meeting the actual company is all email
I had one phone call where we could
barely understand each other because of
language barrier we're in Shenzhen I
wired my five thousand dollars for the
tool to be the the mold to be made
because it was it was actually cheaper
just to wire five grand than to fly over
there meet them have a business trip and
I just figure okay we'll just go for it
and they ended up being legitimate and
we were profitable from day one because
it was just me one employee we just had
no overhead and rolled one good
production run into another and slowly
scaled it and the GoPro that that
everybody knows today has been built on
two hundred and sixty-five thousand
dollars of capital the hero4 session is
the first gopro we've ever released that
didn't immediately take off
it wasn't just that we're selling
against you know here that the strength
of hero4 black and silver we also daft
it and priced at home what I'm proud of
is that when we recognize that we missed
priced GoPro and that it wasn't in the
interest of the customer and the
customer just wasn't giving on it who
changed it it's not the last time we're
gonna make moves like that to a radical
that are in favor of the customers
experience but if we can keep doing that
we can keep differentiating ourselves
from how a lot of other businesses
operate and that differentiation is part
of what makes this company so special
how do you keep GoPro what you're famous
for how do you keep keep it than the
best best of the bunch well having
failed a couple times I recognize that
your business can always go away you can
never get complacent because I've had it
all taken away from you before and so
it's important to wake up every morning
a little bit scared that that might
happen never think that you've finally
made it
Jami scare you does Apple scary no no no
actually competition is a really good
thing because yeah of course they scare
you a little bit that's a good thing
because it drives you it motivates you
to put more into your work to stay
running and stay running hard and that's
a something that we is alive and well at
our culture and I think it's also
important to never let yourself stop
being a startup stop trying to reinvent
yourself you get a new video all the
time all the time
so this is actually a video of a
firefighter rescuing and resuscitating
kitten yeah and a video like that would
very easily go viral around the world oh
my god yeah and that's essentially
commercial for GoPro essentially a
commercial for GoPro
it's a marketers dream and it's all
based off of authenticity right it's
it's our customers doing interesting
things around the world and they're so
stoked that they're able to finally self
document these things that they like to
do and share with people they're so
stoked at how good they look in the
video that when they share the video
they often give us credit my GoPro ski
trip my GoPro day at the park with my
kids you're the only CEO or interviewed
who's use the word stoked like 5 million
times yes well you know it's it's you
you you've got to stay true to who you
are and and I recognize that my approach
to life and our now our company's
approach to life is what has made GoPro
what it is and so there's no reason to
change that everybody around me their
parents were lawyers or investment
bankers or entrepreneurs or they were
all laying involved in business and that
actually didn't seem very much fun to me
growing up so I thought that being an
adult's kind of a drag I actually was
pretty depressed when I graduated from
college
Mel's literally depressed for like six
months I woke up at one o'clock in the
afternoon and laid on a couch and looked
up at the ceiling just do one
and so with no inspiration I just
decided you know what
the only thing I can think of to do
right now is gonna make me happy is if I
go surfing as I planned a five-month
trip around Australian Indonesia living
out of a backpack in a van at the time
if I didn't follow my passion for
surfing I would have never had the idea
for GoPro
you have got to be relentless one of the
one of the one of the things that's
really benefited GoPro is a healthy dose
of fear that you're gonna get taken out
by somebody and a healthy enthusiasm for
all of your great ideas and being
impatient as hell to bring them to
reality and you know having failed in
business before scared the hell out of
me and that you know I still wake up
scared that it's all gonna go away right
out less scared than I used to be but it
happens and you know it's just you you
can never say we made it because that's
when you get hit by the competitive
truck or a surfboard or a surfboard and
so you you have to stay scared and you
also have to really really really be
relentless and I always think about it
what is the other company doing the
other the other guy or gal what is their
mindset and how can we be more
aggressive than them how can we have a
more aggressive roadmap development
timeline to where we just absolutely
outpace the competition just where them
into the ground and I think that that's
been one of the secrets to our success
if you look at our our development
product release history from the hero to
the hero to to the hero 3 to the hero 3
plus to the hero 4 we've launched five
new cameras in the last 11 months we've
made significant advancements in our
software all the while expanding our
global marketing growing into more than
40,000 retail stores with our in-store
retail merchandisers in every single
store
and then once we have those in store
that's not enough now we need to grow
footprints so we grow from two linear
feet of retail merchandising shelf space
to now twelve feet in big stores like
Best Buy and even our smaller format
stores are going from you know two to
five to some eight feet of linear so you
can you can never be done so you gotta
be relentless you have to be relentless
and as soon as you are losing steam
you've got to bring people into your
business that can add a relentless
passion to it and if you don't feel like
you're relentless
chances are they're you're competing
against somebody who is and it's it's a
race as long as you can bootstrap not at
the sacrifice of competitive advantage
meaning not leaving yourself open not
moving so slowly that you leave yourself
to be eaten alive by your competitors
bootstrapping is a really powerful thing
because it allows you to be totally
devoted to your vision and not have to
deal with the pressures of investors to
maybe realize milestones and unrealistic
timelines sure or you know everybody has
an idea over time of what the business
should be and when the business is going
well people leave you alone but I think
maybe during the formative period too
many opinions could be disruptive and so
I know it
it really helped GoPro that we didn't
have to answer to anybody for years I
think an example is when we as soon as
we could afford it we bought a race car
and we went racing up at Sonoma Raceway
in Sonoma and I learned how to drive a
race car and I became our chief R&D
developer for motorsport
when you're the founder you can do
whatever you want yeah but you know if
we've had investors at that point they
might have questioned you know is this
really
of company proceeds and in the end it
led to one of the biggest ideas that we
ever had at GoPro which was to get the
camera off of the wrist and make
mounting accessories so that you could
use the camera mount the camera in any
way imaginable and the way that that
happened was I was in racing school and
they wanted to charge me a bunch of
money to put a camera on the car and I
thought that's crazy I've got my wrist
camera in my trunk of my streetcar I
went and got it strapped it to the roll
bar and the light bulb went off and it
was literally like I could see GoPros
mounted all over the place and I got
chills and until then we had been a
little wrist camera company plodding
along and then that was a major hockey
stick moment for the company that was
totally inspired by climbing into a race
car which is not you know what a Board
of Directors would normally think was a
great idea I had a deal with my parents
that I got into to Berkeley but I didn't
get in here and I was terrified of going
to Berkeley because it was so close to
home and my parents said well you you
know you know what we said about you
being able to pick where you go to
school yeah as soon as you got into
Berkeley that choice went away you're
going there and I made a deal with them
that if I could get into San UC San
Diego would they let me go here this is
where I wanted to go it and my
motivation was it was the best education
combined with the best surf I mean just
just just being just me honest and I
wrote a very earnest letter of Appeal
and thank God I got in and the rest is
the rest is is the history that were
continuing to write yeah what what was
the case that you made you remember yeah
I I promised that I would I would really
buckle down and put my put my head down
why are you laughing my wife is laughing
I made the Dean's List in my freshman
year I think I made it I think I made it
once or twice and then kind of fell from
there but I promise to really devote
myself and and and and make the most out
of the education that I wasn't coming to
party that I wasn't coming just to screw
around that if UC San Diego would give
me the opportunity I would really make
something of myself at the school and
and so that's you know thanks for taking
a flyer on me and the lesson there just
is never give up never give up because
if I went to Berkeley I don't think I
would have had the I you know that life
is a winding path and I just don't think
I would have had the same interests and
inspiration there that led me ultimately
to my idea for GoPro
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because gr nhy asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur you want me to
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I also love
to know which of the top 10 rules have
the biggest impact on you and why leave
it in the comments and I will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon
the secret to GoPros
success people wonder how did you
cashflow the business was we learned
early on that our international
distributors would pay fo B Hong Kong
right so they would pay when we would
ship to them from Hong Kong so we would
in the day get paid by our international
customers before we even known owed the
factory the money right and we went
against the grain and we built our
international business first because
they would pay up front and Lee loves
the international revenue to build the
domestic business which is the inverse
of what traditional business logic would
tell you which is build your your
domestic brand first and then take it
overseas but I don't know that that
really works this day and age you pretty
much have to build globally quickly or
else somebody else will do it for you
everything you need to succeed in life
is already out there you don't need a
ton of money and just go be scrappy and
be dedicated and and you can you can
build your own GoPro